[Applause]
[Music]
okay all right I'm awesome let's get on
with the show
No thank you very much and I know why
you're a peds not me it's cuz trumps out
of the country yeah he went to the big
g7 meeting every year our allies in
Canada and he didn't want to go and they
didn't want him there but he went right
on schedule that turn showed up in the
punch bowl
and when he arrived at the border the
Canadians they wanted to give a little
taste of his own medicine so they
separated him from his daughter
the Canadians are furious with Trump
because he slapped tariffs on their
medals and he said it was based on
national security reasons so their Prime
Minister Trudeau calls up Trump and says
you know we are the most peaceable
nation on earth and your closest ally
really national security reasons and
Trump says this is not the joke part
this is what he really said Trump said
didn't you guys once burned down the
White House and Trudeau says are you
referring to the war of 1812 and Trump
says maybe when was it
yeah in 1812 the British burned down the
White House
Trudeau tells him he says look we
weren't even a country in 1812 who told
you that and Trump said Frederick
Douglass so so he's there now in keeping
with his new wonderful tradition of
alienating the countries who we share
our values with he argued with them that
Russia should be there and they said to
him you're here what's the difference
then like the boria's he left early
skipped the climate part boring he said
it was too busy with other bigger things
he got big deal to think about he spent
all last week preparing for his meeting
with Kim Kardashian not the Korean as as
for North Korea he bragged yesterday
that he didn't prepare didn't prepare of
course when has he ever prepared for
anything this guy didn't bring a condom
to [ __ ] a porn star so we'll see what it
we'll see what happens
at the big summit but put me down for
preparation is good I'm on that team I
mean we don't know much about North
Korea but we do know this Asians do
prepare for the test
let's see who else did the president
piss off this week Philadelphia he saw
that indeed the champion Super Bowl
champion Eagles we're gonna go to the
White House but Trump said no they who
disinvited because they took a knee even
though none of them took a knee so he
had his own big hoopla he said with real
Eagle fans at the White House really go
fans because they look suspiciously like
interns who worked at the White House
and congressional staffers in fact a
photographer went around and asked all
of them do you know who the Eagles
quarterback is they did not know another
little giveaway the only chant they knew
was lock her up
speaking of locking people up yeah don't
get your hopes up that it's gonna happen
to Trump he tweeted this week I have the
absolute right to pardon myself but why
would I do that because I've done
nothing wrong I don't know why even
bring it up if you've done nothing wrong
[Music]
I don't usually get excited about the
space news but this is pretty
interesting in the paper today you see
the Mars rover the rover we got up there
has found what they say are the chemical
building blocks to life so they said
they need to send another mission to
investigate it further Melania said I'll
go hey they found Melania for a very
good body double I don't know it but no
I told you she would turn up right
everything's fine she was living in a
safe house under the name I want to go
home now